[Music]
congratulations are in order for the
Bachelorette Rachael Lindsey and her
fiance Brian Abba solo the newly engaged
couple sat down with Chris Harrison
on after the final rose on Monday after
their proposal aired if it's meant to be
it's meant to be and it was apparently
it's meant to be yeah yeah well the
couple also talked future plans and
answered the burning question bachelor
nation is dying to know when's the
wedding not details but a time of season
you know we want to do well she wants to
do a winter wedding and whatever she
wants to guess we just want to see like
build our lives together and like get to
know each other in a normal sense later
on Jimmy Kimmel Live the pair played a
little game of Bachelorette special
tacular where Rachel had the option to
choose another suitor but of course she
chose Brian I think I'll stick with
bride
you're gonna stick with Brian all right
well let's see what you didn't pick
please reveal what is behind door number
two sorry Rachel you lost you could have
had Guillermo
yeah you
[Music]
you